So let's, let's take somebody as an example. Let's take, uh,
our mutual friend Vladimir Putin. Yes. Okay.
I don't know why he's saying his name makes my voice crack.
Cause you scared he could hear you beetle juice Elijah.
So there's a lot of people that Steve, the one who built, you.
Know.
That was a, that was a collaboration. Um, what's,
it's a double blind engineering effort
where I was not told of who my maker was.
There's a backstory, but um, there's a talking cricket,
you the real voice.
I talk about him quite a bit because I find him fascinating.
Now there's a, there's a really important line that people say like,
why does Lex admire Putin? I do not admire Putin.
I find the man fascinating. I find Hitler. Fascinating.
I find a lot of figures in history. Fascinating,
both good and bad.
And the figures just as you said,
that are with us today, like vitamin or Putin, like Donald Trump,
like Barack Obama is difficult to play some on the spectrum of good and evil
because that's the only really applies to like when you see the consequences of
their actions, there's no historical context.
So there's some people who say that Vladimir Putin is evil.
And based on our discussion about Hitler,
that's something I think about a lot, which is in the room with Putin.
And there's also a lot of historical descriptions of what it's like to be
in the room with Hitler in the 1930s. There,
there is a lot of charisma in the same way. I find Putin to be,
uh, very charismatic in his own way. The humor, the wit the brilliance,
the there's, um,
there's a simplicity of the way he thinks
that really if taken at face value
looks like a very intelligent, honest man
thinking practically about how to build a better Russia
constantly, almost like, um, that can executive,
like he loves, he,
he looks like a man who loves his job in a way that Trump, for example,
doesn't right. Meaning like he loves laws and rules and how to,
uh, no adversarial press. So that's going to help we, yes.
And he's popular with his people. That's also going to help northwesterly.
I'm talking about strictly the man,
the words coming out of his mouth, like all the videos and interviews I watched,
um, based on that, not the press, not the reporting.
You can just see that here's a man who's able to display
a charisma. That's not like I can see. That's why I love Joe Rogan.
That is like, you could tell the guy is genuine and there's a good person.
And I, you could tell immediately that like once you meet Joe,
that he's going to be offline also good person.
You could tell there's like signals that we send that are like difficult to kind
of describe in the same way you can tell Putin is
like,
he genuinely loves his job and wants to build a better Russia.
There's the argument that he is action, evil man,
behind that charisma, or is able to, you know,
assassinate people of no limit, free press,
all those kinds of things. Like that's
what do we do with that?
So what do human beings like journalists,
or what do other leaders,
when they're in the room with Putin do with those kinds of notions
in deciding how to act in this world and deciding what policy to enact,
all those kinds of things. Just like with Hitler,
when a chairman is in the room with Hitler,
how does he decide how to act?
Let's go back to like my real house, which is North Korea, right? So,
uh, when your entire world is based on, uh,
being against Trump and everything Trump does is buffoonery or,
or kind of productive,
the conclusion of your reporting is going to be pretty much a given.
I was very hopeful that there would be some positive outlooks or outcomes
rather of Trump's meeting with Kim Jong-un. Um,
it looked like there was a space for things to go a bit better.
I talked about a lot at the time. Um, and
Trump was under no illusions about who he was dealing with.
Um, people pretend that, Oh, he was kind of naive.
He had one of the refugees that state stayed the union, you know,
lifting up his crutch. Uh,
the first thing he sat down and talked to Jean ping about in Mar-a-Lago right
after he became inaugurated was North Korea.
Barack Obama said that when he sat down Trump in the white house during the
transfer of power, he said, North Korea is the biggest issue.
So I think a good leader, whether or not you consider Trump,
a good leader has to be aware of all right,
I'm going to have to have relationships of some kind,
even if it's adversarial with some really evil, evil,
horrible people, which Kim juggling clearly is.
Well,
I don't think there's anybody that has a perspective that Norco North Korean,
Kim Jong-un on or ill.
Are not evil. Right? Correct.
But with in 1930s, Germany,
isn't it a little bit more nuanced because Hitler hasn't done anything yet and
he's just a blowhard and he's an anti-Semite shore,
but he's what about like before the war breaks out?
Like what about the basic, uh,
actionable anti-Semitism when you're like just attacking,
hurting crystal enough? We'll talk about overnight a long knives, uh,
Kristallnacht night of the broken glass and the long nights is when he
assassinated a bunch of his people. That was something different. Yeah.
So like when you're actually attacking your own citizenry yeah.
That was universally condemned Kristallnacht. And that was very shocking.
Uh, it's its level of barbarism, um, uh, to the West, because I think,
I think we still want to believe understandably
that things aren't as bad as they seem.
We would rather, this is why I, you know, I,
the North Korea book I did dear reader is used in a humorous
framework because if you have to look, it's like looking to the sun,
if you stare at it straight on,
it's very hard to do so you have to kind of look at it obliquely. And,
and then it kind of realizing the enormity of the depravity.
Um, and again,
pogroms in Russia had been a thing for a very long time and there is a
difference between, okay, you know,
we're going to sack these villages and persecute people and we're going to
systematically exterminate them. That's th there's,
there's still levels of evil and depravity.